as leaders met the desperate pressed on
seizing the opportunity while Turkey's
borders were still open
Abdul sodden describes a harrowing
journey that ended with an arrest by the
Greek police globalize is not crying for
myself I'm ready to die On February 28
hours after Turkey suffered its greatest
number of casualties since its soldiers
began fighting in Syria turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan opened
the country's Northwest border with
Greece and Bulgaria
Irwin's new policy or not a frustration
with what he says is Europe's failure to
assist it with hosting 3.7 million
Syrians created another refugee and
geopolitical crisis dramedy see Turkey
has a critical role to play in handling
the refugee problem and it needs the
help of Europe to do it but this cannot
happen and I think everyone realizes it
now under conditions of threats and
blackmail using fling people as pawns
Greece may call it blackmail but some
analysts say turkey's opening of the
border is a successful tactic after two
years of complaining to the european
union to no avail
president Erdogan now has Europe's
attention and is back at the negotiating
table on Monday President Erdogan spoke
after meeting with the NATO
secretary-general
the Kangxi Kenan is beyond reason and
understanding that an ally and a
neighboring country points towards
Turkey as the one responsible for the
wave of irregular migration and I have
expressed to the secretary-general that
we are not going to allow this country
to use this current situation and use
the European Union in order to obtain in
just games top EU officials said the
2016 migration agreement between Turkey
and the EU is still valid however there
are missing elements that need to be
addressed under the agreement turkey
agreed to impose strict measures to halt
the flow of migration into Europe in
exchange for billions of
dollars we have expressed very clearly
to President Aldo on our commitment to
move forward on these issues provided
that this is reciprocal the European
Council president called the meetings of
first step leaving the question of how
much longer it would take to end the
crisis as thousands of refugees and
migrants continue to risk their lives
making their way to Western Europe
Natasha ganado al Jazeera a dern day
near the turkey grease border